[Music]
serena williams is trying to win her
first Wimbledon since becoming a mom and
it looks as if she's going to get some
royal support I don't know we'll see you
I keep winning yesterday Serena won her
first match in our royal source tells ET
that megan is likely to cheer on her
good pal sometime next week
over the weekend Serena and her husband
Alexis Ohanian were Meghan's gas at
Prince Harry's polo match
I enjoyed polo it was really fun it's
it's a good intense sport you know I
feel like it's you know they're going
sometimes 45 miles an hour and I didn't
know at this at all for me it's very
scary but wow it's there respectable in
2016 right before her first date with
Harry Megan sat in the players box to
root for Serena
her sister-in-law Duchess Kate is a
feature of Wimbledon and is also
expected to attend an upcoming match but
who knew Kate also had a sarena
connection here's a snapchat from two
years ago and another royal news William
and Harry are going on display these
never-before-seen portraits of the
brothers from 2009 will soon be shown at
Buckingham Palace the works are from the
private collection of their father
Prince Charles and the public release of
the paintings are to celebrate his
upcoming 70th birthday
[Music]